hey 42 here the Sun takes 220 million
years to orbit the galaxy a journey it
has made 20 times so far welcome to RIF
more than half the world's population is
under 25 and more than half of it is
bilingual coca-cola in the Maldives is
made from seawater
in 1567 the man said to have the longest
beard in the world died after he tripped
over his beard whilst running away from
a fire the common shrew protects itself
from predators by dying of fright 95% of
all data in the world is still stored on
paper most of it is never looked at
again the world's deepest post box is in
Sioux Sami Bey in Japan it's 10 meters
underwater in the Inuit language anak T
taught there is a word that looks like
this and it means I should try not to
become an alcoholic the strongest
creatures on earth are gonorrhea
bacteria they can pull 100,000 times
their own body weight in 1997 39 people
in the UK found themselves in hospital
with tea cosy related injuries both
gorillas and potatoes have two more
chromosomes than people more gold is
recoverable from a ton of personal
computers than from 17 tons of gold or
2520 is the smallest number that can be
exactly divided by all the numbers
between one to ten it takes ten times as
much energy to heat water as it does to
heat iron the dance fever of 1518 was a
month-long plague of inexplicable
dancing in Strasbourg in which hundreds
of people danced for about a month
no apparent reason several of them
danced themselves to death Alexander the
Great
washed his hair in saffron to keep it
shiny and orange thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you